[Music]
mass vaccinations
eased restrictions
and reopened borders
if 2021 was the year the world turned
the tide against covid19
what's to come in 2022
year the economist turns its unrivaled
skill at understanding the future to the
next 12 months
led by editor of the world ahead tom
standage our experts predict the key
trends and stories in the coming year
here's tom with a personal preview of
some of next year's biggest themes
we sort of hope that we'll go from
pandemic to endemic in 2022 and that the
the the coronavirus will become a sort
of manageable disease that we can live
with and we've we've started to get to
get to that position in some western
countries with high levels of
vaccination the real challenge is going
to be to get vaccination up everywhere
not just in the rich world and the
omicron
variant is a reminder that you know as
the the head of the who likes to say no
one is safe until everyone is safe and
we've also got these new therapies
showing up in 2022 antiviral pills and
that again is a very important weapon
against um the coronavirus in general
but also against omicron because um
those antivirals work by suppressing the
replication of rna that's what
viruses rrna and they essentially hijack
the cell in the machinery to copy
themselves and these pills interfere
with that process and that will mean
that they still work against omicron
2022 is i think the year when we're
really going to have to start figuring
out the rules for hybrid working it
turns out women and men involved in
child care are less keen on going back
to the office because it's harder to
juggle work and child care and it also
turns out there are racial disparities
as well white workers are much more
likely to say that they want to go back
to the office than people of color
there's an amazing survey that slack did
that found that three percent of of
information workers of black information
workers said they wanted to go back to
the office full-time versus 21 of white
information workers that was in america
um because maybe offices aren't such
welcoming places if you're not white and
a manager so the worrying possibility
here is that the sort of young white men
all go back to the office they get all
the face time with the managers they get
promoted um they get the pay rises and
that you know the world ends up going
backwards on things like gender pay gaps
and diversity in the workplace
well it's been a lot of enthusiasm for
decentralized finance for crypto uh for
blockchains and so on in uh in 2021 and
it's starting to be taken more seriously
uh by you know mainstream banks and
companies and regulators and so on i
think more broadly what we're seeing
here is the emergence of three sort of
rival visions for the future of finance
the future of money the future of
banking
we've got the sort of tech industry view
of this
so you know companies like facebook you
know trying to launch their own
currencies then you've got the
decentralized finance blockchain crypto
crowd who say well the problem with
those big tech companies is that they're
very centralized
and you know they're too powerful and
then you've got the central bank saying
well hang on a sec if someone's going to
issue digital currencies around here
shouldn't it be us so i think we're
going to see this sort of three-way
battle between these three different
visions and i think in some form or
another we are going to see crypto being
sort of domesticated we've seen this
with with previous technologies that you
know the uh the radical vision is not
quite what we end up with in the end we
get some sort of compromise between the
new way of doing things and the old way
of doing things
we've got a number of space races going
on at the same time here uh in 2021 we
saw three american companies sort of
fighting to um to be the first to put
more tourists into space so we saw
virgin galactic blue origin and spacex
all sent tourists to space what we're
expecting to see in 2022 is more
launches from those companies spacex's
new rocket
called starship which is going to
probably do its first orbital flight in
january or february if that works that
really does change the economics both
for space tourism but also for um this
sort of great power uh rivalry because
america wants to go back to the moon to
remind everybody actually it's top dog
in space and it's it's hoping to use
spacex's technology for part of that and
in particular this starship as the
lander
well i think the general consensus is
that cop 26 you know was a rather
disappointing outcome i mean at least
things didn't go backwards but things
didn't go forward very quickly either a
lot of companies are sort of stepping up
and saying well if governments aren't
going to do things then we're going to
make big you know bold gestures or big
bold sort of promises that we're going
to cut our own emissions we have a piece
by marjun who is a leading chinese
environmentalist in the world ahead
annual and he's saying well the obvious
way for the west and china to cooperate
on this would be for western companies
who do a lot of their manufacturing in
china um to sort of make sure that
they're choosing the lowest carbon
providers in china so his ngo has
produced this database of 10 million
companies in china
and sort of you know how
carbon friendly they are so the idea is
that western companies when they're
choosing suppliers in china can choose
the lowest carbon providers and that
will then lead naturally to competition
between those providers to to reduce
their carbon footprint so i hope that
there will be you know scope for the
private sector to step up here given
that we're not really seeing
the kind of progress we'd like to see
from from governments
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage of the themes to watch in
2022 click the link and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]
you